hold off on your dinner plans I'm Brian
Kilmeade One Nation ready to start
tonight on the show here's just three of
our great guests Congressman Michael
Waltz on the crime in DC You're Gonna
Love It Tommy Lair an inside uh baseball
like you never talked before and Dan
Rooney why are more men and women
volunteering and going into the military
we'll discuss it all
but first I want to begin with this the
biggest problem facing our nation and
you don't have to look very far to find
them they're staring us right in the
face threatening our safety and
well-being on a daily basis now for me
and you it's pretty clear to see it's
China and our border major problems that
need to be addressed need to be
addressed now but the first step in
fixing a problem I believe is admitting
you have a problem in the first place
and the bite Administration just cannot
seem to do it
how would you describe the fentanyl
problem in America it's a horrible
epidemic but it's an epidemic that's
been Unleashed on purpose by the Sinaloa
um and the new generation Jalisco
cartels all right so what is missing
about what the AG described the Genesis
of fentanyl in our country yes we know
the cartels have it yes they smuggle it
in and over our border they send it here
but the real question is where do they
really get the precursors where do they
get it from and that's why Garland left
out in his testimony the real problem it
is China but somehow you are
hard-pressed to find anyone in the
entire Administration with any urgency
to attack the problem at its core
weaponizing fentanyl is not just an
adult problem it is a problem targeting
our children our next Generation
two-thirds of drug overdose deaths in
our nation come from Fentanyl and among
children young people debts are rising
faster than any other group this does
that concern you it should maybe it's
because fentanyl is up to 50 times
stronger than heroin and should never
make its way from the hand into the
hands of our youth in the first place
and of course it would be great if they
never took a drug that wasn't prescribed
by a doctor we all know that's not
realistic as an Administration you can
go a long way to curb the Temptation by
attacking the problem head on but for
this Administration for whatever reason
they just will not take it seriously
issues very specific recently saying
that a mom a poor mother who lost two
kids to fentanyl that that I killed her
sons
well the interesting thing is that
fentanyl they took came during the last
Administration
yeah nice laugh but there's nothing
funny about it fentanyl uh is not funny
Joe because more often than not it's one
and you're done
you're an emergency room doctor
what does death look like
from fentanyl right so opioids just
cause respiratory suppression so it just
people just stop breathing and then they
pass out and then they turn blue and
then they die if not resuscitated
so it's almost like they're being
smothered
or right or the same the same thing with
an execution this is it can be the same
thing as a chemical execution wow
what is it like when a chemical
execution happens on your kid or our
kids who decided one day that like a
painkiller or like some Ritalin to focus
and they end up dead
just what a horrible human being how can
he sit there and joke about it you know
he thought he was with a room full of
Democrats and you know he's amongst
friends and they can all yuck it up
uh
um what kind of a person does that
so okay
how many more parents have to go through
this the push your fentanyl from China
through our border is too real and
astounding to us and to all of us that
we're letting it happen but on the other
side there doesn't seem to be much alarm
I apologize for yelling and screaming
but you know what I've been dealing with
the families for many years and there's
no action going on in this town so I
will tell you this I will tell you in
action let me let me ask let me answer
the question first of all I would
appreciate if you stop calling it an
overdose it's a poisoning and it's a war
against our kids so stop with the
overdosing that's part of the problem
the American public thinks it's a
substance
wow when was the last time you heard a
congressman yield back his time
willingly because he did the answer he
was getting the sad truth is the bite
Administration cannot fix these problems
because they will not accept these
problems maybe that's why 75 percent of
Democrats want someone else leading
their party in 2024. everyone on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now